it looks like Creed 3 is Going the
Distance it's a franchise movie with big
name stars but its box office take is
still shattering expectations how is
this boxing epic punching so high above
its weight
the first two Creed movies were released
on Wednesdays over the Thanksgiving
holiday weekend Creed 3 by contrast
opened on a Friday over a weekend with
no major holidays since it wasn't
burning off Demand with Wednesday launch
it's no shock Creed 3 had a bigger
three-day opening weekend than its
predecessors what's impressive though is
that Creed 3 left the five-day Halls of
the first two Creed films in the dust
over just three days with its staggering
58.4 million dollar take Creed 2 made 56
million dollars over its first five days
of release I'm coming for everything
Creed 3 was even further ahead of the
first Creed which made 42 million
dollars in its first five days it took
11 days for the first Creed to narrowly
exceed what Creed 3 AM asked in three
comparing the opening weekend of pre 3
to the original Rocky movies is a bit
trickier since those movies were
released in a drastically different time
but it's worth noting Creed 3 did nearly
five times the 12.1 million dollar debut
of the 2006 installment Rocky Balboa
Creed 3 was one of the first films
released by MGM since Amazon scooped up
the legendary Studio MGM and sister
company Orion pictures have released a
handful of smaller titles in theaters
since the acquisition including women
talking and bones and all but Creed 3 is
the first massive MGM release under
Amazon ownership so the movie's opening
weekend made history for Amazon by out
grossing the domestic Halls of every
other flick in Amazon history that
includes not just recent MGM and Orion
releases but all other Amazon Studios
films including Manchester by the Sea
and the big sick to be fair many of
Amazon's previous theatrical releases
were Art House fair that never played in
more than a couple hundred theaters you
are never really here for instance was
never expected to be a money maker like
a Creed movie could be so the success of
the sequel opens more doors for Amazon
the massive debut of Creed 3
demonstrates that Amazon is capable of
launching MGM movies in a big way and
redefines the level of box office
success the company's movies can reach
Sports dramas usually need a little time
to warm up at the box office for example
you may remember a little movie called
Remember the Titans that inspirational
classic opened with under 25 million
dollars at the weekend box office and
still pulled in a sizable domestic Hall
thanks to positive word of mouth most
sports dramas aren't big franchise fair
so they're less likely to open like
movies at R this meant that Creed 3 the
newest movie in a long-running storied
series had no trouble scoring the
biggest domestic opening weekend in
history for a sports drama it took the
crown away from the 35.5 million dollar
debut of none other than its own
predecessor Creed 2. no matter how you
slice it it's pretty impressive just how
far ahead of all other sports movies the
third Creed entry ran in its first three
days release previously no Sports drama
had ever cracked 40 million dollars in
an opening weekend and Creed 3 shattered
that Mark Creed 3 even exceeded the
entire lifetime domestic Halls of
well-regarded sports dramas like
invincible and Southpaw in just one
weekend
man can only take so much failure
Michael B Jordan has been selective
about where he shows up with the actor
only headlining two other theatrical
releases just mercy and a journal for
Jordan since the release of creed 2.
he's made cameos in other movies with
varying degrees of success including
black panther wakanda Forever on the
positive side and Space Jam a new Legacy
on the other side
I was just getting some popcorn and then
this cat grabbed me
except for that one exception as well as
streaming movies like The Tom Clancy
Thriller without remorse he's generally
shown a good deal of shrewdness when it
comes to selecting his projects which
has helped keep him from being too
Overexposed as a leading man with that
in mind Jordan doesn't have a sprawling
box office track record to his name with
a major exception of the first black
panther he's never appeared in a movie
that cracked 40 million dollars on its
three-day opening weekend until Crete 3
in Just Three Days Creed 3 exceeded the
lifetime grosses of many other
theatrical releases Jordan appeared in
such as the 2015 Fantastic Four reboot
and Red Tails while its clear audiences
like Jordan as a presence Creed 3 blew
away all expectations for how big a
Michael B Jordan star vehicle could go
in general Rocky movies have been
holiday season Staples while the second
and third Rocky entries each opened in
the summer the other original Rocky
movies all hit theaters in November and
December it's a time frame that served
the franchise well especially since he
all ages appeal and uplifting Spirit to
the franchise feels like the perfect
thing families can watch together during
the holidays the first two Creed movies
also opened over Thanksgiving but Creed
3 went in a different direction with its
March 2023 release it's reasonable to
assume that there was some trepidation
about an early spring release but even
if there was there turned out to be
nothing to worry about March has
actually become a go-to month where
blockbuster hits with the Batman finding
success in 2022 and Captain Marvel doing
the same in 2019 among many others
release date Traditions served the Rocky
movies well in the past but Creed 3
excelling in March proved that it's okay
to do something a little unexpected to
throw off your opponents
third movies and franchises are tricky
unlike a second installment audiences
need a little something more than just
this character is back to get them into
the theater that's why many third
installments make noticeably less than
the second entry in a franchise Harry
Potter and the Prisoner of Azkaban for
instance had the lowest domestic gross
for any Harry Potter film until the
Fantastic Beasts movies came along and
The Hangover Part 3 made substantially
Less in North America than either of its
predecessors there was reason to assume
Creed III could suffer the same box
office fate to so many other third
installments especially if you consider
it as the ninth movie in the larger
Rocky franchise yet the film's opening
weekend showed a franchise with lots of
gas left in the tank wearing
catastrophic weekend to weekend dips
Creed 3 will have no problem surpassing
the lifetime North American Halls of the
first two Creed movies an impressive
feat and one that's incredibly rare
among third installments since black
panther wakanda forever is massive 181.3
million dollar opening weekend in
November 2022. only two other movies
have managed to crack 40 million dollars
in their domestic opening weekends
Avatar the way of water and Ant-Man in
the WASP quantumania of course Megan and
cocaine bear proved to be surprise
sleeper hits but there haven't been a
ton of Temple releases to drum up
significant opening weekends that means
Creed 3 scored the third biggest
domestic opening weekend since wakanda
forever and the second biggest single
weekend Hall in 2023 to date
impressively Creed 3 managed the 18th
biggest domestic opening weekend for any
movie since a covid-19 pandemic shut
down movie theaters in March 2020 with
many of the titles that surpassed it
carrying significantly bigger budgets
and marketing spends
with the original Rocky movie sequels
came out at a rapid Pace across the
first four installments audiences never
had to wait more than three years to see
where Rocky Balboa was going next the
steady Pace ended up backfiring on the
franchise though when Rocky 5 took so
long to make a five-year wait ended up
killing the financial momentum of The
Saga with Rocky 5 making drastically
less than its predecessors in North
America Rocky Balboa and Creed did fine
at the box office despite coming off
lengthy hiatuses if anything the long
wait helped these flicks because they
were Legacy sequels a lengthy wait time
gave them their emotional oomph
traditional Rocky sequels judging by the
original films needed to be made quickly
so one might have guessed that Creed 3
arriving nearly five years after Creed 2
could have tanked the Creed movies
financially instead Creed 3 once again
bucked the trend if anything the weight
seems to obey the hearts of moviegoers
grow fonder for Adonis Creed
Creed 3 was never expected to be a
lightweight at the box office but
initial tracking for its opening weekend
didn't suggest it would shatter box
office records Pro box office reported
at the start of February 2023 that Creed
3 was tracking for a 25 million dollars
to 34 million domestic debut on the low
end that meant Creed 3 would have opened
considerably beneath its predecessors
though a 34 million dollar take would
have at least been ahead of the first
Creed as late as one week before its
release Pro box office was still
predicting Creed 3 would open as low as
29 million dollars in its first three
days of release in North America many
industry insiders assumed that there was
nowhere to go but down after Creed 2.
just days before its debut deadline
predicted Creed 3 would take in 38 to 40
million dollars bigger than earlier
tracking projections but still nowhere
near what Creed 3 would end up amassing
on opening weekend the some Creed 3
ended up amassing was more than double
the lowest initial tracking figures for
its opening weekend
the ending of Creed 2 gave Sylvester
Stallone an out to leave the franchise
behind
it's your turn
[Music]
the film's final moment saw Rocky Balboa
finally traveling to Chicago to visit
his son Rocky Balboa Jr and Grandson
Logan it was a reunion that suggested
that despite all of the turmoil of the
past Balboa could have a happy future
with his loved ones Stallone made it
clear that he wouldn't be returning to
the role of Rocky and Creed 3 in an
interview with The Hollywood Reporter
saying that the tone in the movie was
darker than what he would have preferred
variety also noted that Stallone has bad
blood with serious producer Irwin
Winkler over ownership of the rocky
character a sign he might never return
to the role that kick-started his career
so there was some question as to how
successful Creed 3 would be without
Rocky on the poster but clearly it
wasn't a problem impressively the film's
North America opening weekend even
managed to surpass the opening three-day
grosses of every single movie Sylvester
Stallone has ever appeared in with the
exception of Guardians of the Galaxy Vol
2. at the end of the day Creed 3 didn't
just manage to survive without Stallone
it's surpassing the box office track
record of the man who was along the
focal points of the franchise
Creed 3 was the first of an intense
slate of movies in March 2023. new
installments in the scream Shazam and
John Wick franchises are all opening
while Dungeons and Dragons honor among
Thieves is also prepped to debut at the
end of the month with so many
high-profile Motion Pictures poised the
fight for dollars and the intention of
moviegoers in a single month it's easy
to see a scenario where Creed 3 could
have gotten lost in the shuffle perhaps
there just wouldn't be room for a boxing
drama amidst all the superheroes and
assassins instead Creed 3 opened up with
a bang and set a high bar if anything
the successive Creed 3 puts added
pressure on the fourth John Wick to
surpass the box office Hall of its
predecessors Creed 3 kicked off one of
the most loaded months in recent memory
with impressive style much of the buzz
around Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
since its release has surrounded its
sharp box office decline with a feature
experiencing the worst second weekend
drop ever for a Marvel Cinematic
Universe movie the trend continued with
the film's third weekend decline of 60
which indicates that the second weekend
drop was no fluke quantumania is being
weighed down by dismal audience word of
mouth after a solid opening weekend this
lack of staying power is especially
interesting to see in comparison to
Creed 3 which showed remarkable stamina
on a day-to-day basis during its first
few days of release at Thursday night
showings Creed 3 secured 5.5 million
dollars from moviegoers a sizeable take
that already put it on track for a great
opening weekend its subsequent 58.4
million dollar debut was more than 10
times its Thursday night hole an
impressive amount of retention
indicating that Creed 3 was attracting
audiences all throughout the weekend for
comparison's sake bullet train did 4.6
million dollars at Thursday night
showings and ended up doing 30.1 million
dollars for its first weekend or about
six and a half times its Thursday night
hole the lack of front loading in the
opening weekend of pre 3 underscores how
impressive its debut was especially
since it was coming hot off the wheels
of quantumania which had very poor box
office retention
thank you